(foreboding music)
- [Man] (gasps)
Are you Ms. Tubman?
- The name's Harriet.
- Well, thank God in Heaven
for the work that you're doing, Harriet.
(upbeat music)
- Before you thank me, let me tell you.
I've led hundreds of slaves to freedom
through this here underground railroad.
But it ain't goin' be easy.
Are you ready?
All right,
then hike up your breeches
and follow me to freedom!
(screams)
(hopeful music)
Watch this Black-Molasses!
(shouts)
- Well, where is she now?!
- That was the easy part.
Now stay close,
this next 500 miles gets a little sticky.
(exhilarated shouting)
- Forget this, man. I'm goin' back.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
(funk music)
♪ Got a pocket full of funky ♪
♪ With a peppermint twist ♪
♪ She's a cool, shifty mama ♪
♪ Blasting off on the flip ♪
♪ Iridescent pork belly
galactic super train ♪
♪ Mama sister playground
with a straw daddy cane ♪
♪ Uh-Huh ♪
♪ Gotta get it up, hey ♪
♪ Gotta get it on, uh-huh ♪
♪ Gotta get it down, hey ♪
♪ Gotta make it strong ♪
♪ Got that quick dip crayon
earthquake jet pack on a bun ♪
♪ Locomotive supernova
Spanish Harlem sun ♪
♪ Slick crawfish solar blast
with a phosphorescent brain ♪
♪ Who's that mama squat town
deep fried Detroit soda train? ♪
♪ Gotta shake it up ♪
♪ Gotta move it in ♪
♪ Gotta put it down ♪
♪ Gotta make it swim ♪
♪ Nebulatic comets sanitation disease ♪
♪ Quick play tornado rip
and tickle beef sneeze ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Ships planets justice
cannons, cables, and trees ♪
♪ Doctor's office penguin
shillings, railroads, and peas ♪
♪ I said crippled donkey
Mel Brooks book train ♪
♪ Bats on my knees ♪
♪ Penicillin trapdoor
laser currency beans ♪
♪ He say penicillin trapdoor
- Hey, what the hell are we saying, man?
- I got no idea, man.
I'm just hungry and talking
about the galaxy and trains.
I think they buying it, though.
(audience cheers)
(audience clapping)
- [Commentator] Live
from the Nestle Arena,
welcome to the finals of
1987 Jazz Fit Championships.
Representing the body shop
from Hollywood, California,
Flash.
(upbeat '80s music)
And from the skin shop
from Detroit, Michigan,
Lightning.
(upbeat '80s music)
(unsettling music)
- You son of a (beep)!
You mother (beep)!
You crazy sick (beep)!
I'm gonna kill you!
(incoherent shouting)
- [Man] Let me through.
This is (beep) Gene!
- Whoa, Whoa, wait,
what's the matter, Rich?
- In the next episode
Steve Urkel turns Carl
into a giant sandwich
and accidentally eats him.
- But wait, that's hilarious
buddy, that's hilarious
- Come on!
I'm an actor, Gene!
This was supposed to be
about me and my family.
I know, but you know
after that- after that first
guest spot with Steve Urkel
I mean America fell in love with him, man.
We had to make him a
regular and now, you know--
Hey, listen, he's the star
of the show now, sweetheart.
We gotta play ball, Bubbeleh.
- Don't you dare "Bubbeleh" me, Gene.
Now, last week, Steve used
his transformation machine
to turn Carl into a car
and drive him around Monaco Grand Prix.
Come on!
How many times you gonna use
this transformation machine?
This was supposed to be
a blue collar Cosby show.
Now you're turning it into
a goddamn Quantum leap?
Who writes this (beep)?
- Okay, I couldn't tell you
even if I wanted to, okay, man?
We got like 21 writers up there, okay,
know what I'm saying Reginald?
But you and I both know
that they don't decide
what happens in this show, okay?
We both know who decides
what happens in the show.
- Two weeks ago Steve Urkel
used his invisibility ray
on Carl
and I wasn't even in the goddamn episode.
It was just my voice.
- Yes, I know!
I know, Reginald. I'm sorry.
I (beep) apologize.
It'll never happen again.
- Then Steve used his voice-changing ray
to turn Carl into a high
pitched nerdy voice.
Who do you think provided
the voice for that?
- Don't get too feisty on me now, Reg.
Let's not go down that path, okay?
- Oh-oh, we are going
down that path, Gene.
In a couple of weeks,
Harriet, Eddie, Laura, Grandma
Aunt Rachel, Little Richie,
and the other little kid
are gonna get teleported
to another dimension.
And then Steve injects
Carl with his own DNA,
so Carl turns into another Steve Urkel.
That's two Steve Urkels and no family
on a show called 'Family Matters'.
How the (beep) does that work?
- Listen, listen, Reginald.
I don't know what to tell you.
Urkel Mania is unstoppable, okay?
He's a phenomenon.
There's nothing we can do about it, okay?
It's up to S--
Him.
- No, no, no, no, no!
I'm an actor. I'm a (beep) actor.
I am a real actor.
I did Richard the Third.
I was in True West with Sherman Hemsley.
I was in Die Hard, damn it.
(beep) Steve Urkel!
- (beep)-- you will suck
Steve Urkel's (beep)
if he wants you to!
You will suck his (beep),
do you understand?
He is our bread and
butter, you mother (beep)!
I am high on cocaine!
- I'm a (beep) actor, Gene!
I done more cocaine than
you weigh, mother (beep)!
- I'm gonna tell you what
you are, Reginald VelJohnson.
You're a (beep) pawn in that nerd's game.
You are a (beep) pawn!
Do you think I have any power
over what that monster does?
Any power at all?
- (shouts)
- I am the senior vice
president of development
for the American broa--
- Gene?
Gene?
Gene, what's become of you, Gene?
- I
am nothing.
- Gene, I don't know what
you mean by that, Gene
but you're scaring me.
Oh, no, don't, don't do
anything crazy, Gene.
Everyone does too much coke sometimes
but do the- just
what are you gonna do with the gun, Gene?
What are you gonna do?
No, no, no, no.
We can talk this through.
Uh- okay?
- The king is dead.
Long live the king.
- No, no, no, no, no!
- Did I do that?
- Jaleel.
- Jaleel?
There is no Jaleel.
Only Steve.
It's always been Steve.
- Yippie Ki-Yay, mother(beep)!
- Forgetting something, Carl?
- Don't you come near me.
Stay away from me, you hear?
- It could have all been so simple, Carl.
Just say your lines and take the money.
- You're a monster.
What are you doing?
I, I, I can't control--
- Am I doing this?
- No, no, no
no, no, no, no, no
Steve, I'll do anything.
- You will do what I
want on Family Matters.
- Yes, yes, of- of course, Steve.
- See you on set, Carl.
- Get out of my house, Steve!
(dramatic music)
(wind blowing)
(foreboding music)
- There's gotta be another
human being out there.
Somewhere.
It's been 173 days since the undoing.
Today, I may be the last man alive.
However, if there is
another, I will find them.
The loneliness is more than I can--
(engine roars)
(man whooping)
- Ha-ha!
- [Man] There we go.
- Let me get some of that.
Mm-mmm. Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
(retro dance music)
That's my jam right there!
(excited shouting)
Oh, y'all don't know nothing 'bout that.
Mm-hmm
- [Man] Oh, hey baby, how you doing?
- Yeah!
- [Man] All day, baby!
- [Man] Yeah!
(loud thud)
- Whoa, hey, dude!
Hey, I- I'll come over there.
- [Man] Dude, hey!
I'll come to you, man.
(gunshot)
(foreboding music)
- There's gotta be another
human being out there.
Somewhere.
(Upbeat music)